all right thank you very much for your
patience
and
welcome everyone to the career master
class how to become a successful
blockchain professional in
2022
our speaker today is myrtlene ramos who
is
the founder of block tides
uh co-founder and ceo of place war
and a noted expert in blockchain
blockchain industry
and i'll introduce her in a moment my
name is stuart creek i'm a marketing
manager here at simply learn i want to
advise you of the
controls of the webex platform we're
using
which is one of the reasons why it took
me a couple minutes to get this
started but please enter your questions
for myrtland in the q a box we will be
queuing those up
and
asking those in the q a portion of the
webinar
you can also
put in a chat message to all panelists
we'll see that while we're going um
not guaranteeing that we'll be able to
respond to those immediately but i'll
also be cueing some of those up
and
we also have a couple of polls
to learn more about your
interest
and your background
and what i'd like to do is start with
this poll if you're watching on live
stream you can put an answer into the
comments
and
basically just asking two questions how
much experience do you have
are you
still in school or are you in the
workforce and how long have you been
there and then
our other question is how are you doing
today we've been asking this throughout
the pandemic
see how people are holding up
and we've got about 10 more seconds on
the pole
let's share the result here
so we have uh
almost 40 percent of our
audience members today are students
um
interestingly the next biggest group are
people
with 10 or more years of experience
so
this is a presentation that should
address the concerns of both groups and
everyone in between so
let's move on
and i will introduce
erdogan
as i mentioned the founder of block
tides which is a pr firm involved in the
blockchain industry um co-founder of
place war
advisor for many companies um i'm going
to let her
give a uh more detailed background as i
introdu um invite her to the stage so
uh welcome myrtle or land and let me um
send
hello can you hear me
yes we hear you all right so and we see
you
all right so
thank you so much simply learn for this
collaboration for place war blog sites
and uh yeah i'm really happy to inspire
motivate and of course impart my
knowledge here
would simply learn because you know
education is very important for me as
well
and it is the best for us to provide
opportunities to many people at the same
time
can you still hear me
yes i yeah we hear you um all right and
do you have the opportunity to share
your screen
okay hold on so let me just go ahead and
share my screen guys can you see my
screen
yes ma'am
all right so first uh this is the career
master class
how to become successful
blockchain profes uh how to become a
successful blockchain professional in
2022 so you know success for me
basically guys is not really with the
titles but it's how you actually uh
provide impact and value to many people
so that's the first key thing that is
really important for me so all of these
titles once you actually reach it there
you'll find uh you'll find it empty
because you know if a lack of purpose at
the same time you'll really crave for
that purpose and impact that you want to
give to the whole world so let's go
ahead and start with my uh introduction
so of course my humble beginnings
started from as a bpo uh
agent so you all know call center right
here in the philippines it's very well
known so just to share you the
background that i have
i've been in the bpo industry for eight
years
so with many technical accounts such as
comcast
apple i've been an advisor as well for
emea for europe for apple
you all know apple right so uh comcast
all of the
service provider in america and the usa
so
all of my experiences came from there
and ever since high school
i really love the computer subject
and then i'm also one of the
scholar graduates for draper university
if you actually know tim draper he's
actually a successful entrepreneur
so he's one of the
idols not really idols but of course um
one of the people that i'm really
following on linkedin
so linkedin guys i do suggest for you
to of course
okay hold on am i
uh he said one of the attendees cannot
hear me so please do check your uh
audios guys
so yeah going back with tim draper
he's also one of the successful
entrepreneurs that i'm looking up to
because you know he just doesn't
actually just
uh give value but he's also helping a
lot of people to be a hero for everyone
so that's where i learned when i became
a scholar graduate i'm one of the chosen
ones for um draper university and yeah
so where i came from in the blockchain
industry so coming from a bpo
how did i became a successful
entrepreneur well i don't really want to
be tagged as successful because you know
success for me is peace and contentment
but yeah
for us to become successful it all
starts with ourselves guys okay how we
think how we mentally do it but of
course when it comes to technical
aspects i'll go deep dive when it comes
to
uh the technical aspects what are the
skills that you need to have
for you to be able to be seen in the
blockchain space all right so
i started as uh doing side gigs for
social media contents for
a blockchain project
way back 2015 i already know bitcoin
cryptocurrency i was skeptical at first
so of course
what is bitcoin it's just like an on
another online scam but of course if you
actually dive deep
follow mentors follow the right
news portal when it comes to blockchain
and cryptocurrency you'll be in the
right path guys
so of course here
uh and then what happened with the
social media management
i gathered a lot of experiences in
knowing the space
and at the same time
there's this one guy from singapore that
i really want to thank
my whole life because he gave me this
breakthrough in organizing a tour for
startups so all of the things when it
comes to handling startups investor
relations i really don't know at first
what i am do am i doing so it's a leap
of faith for me being in the corporate
ladder
uh as a bpo account executive technical
and sales so that's where i came from
and i will never be ashamed of where i
started
because you know that experience has
shaped me so if ever that you're a
student now you're wondering i know
there's a lot of students out here so
this is the chance for you to be able to
know
and define what
is it that you want to have and or
achieve in life okay so let's start
actually
so most of your students here and i'm
pretty excited because i also introduce
myself to a thousand uh students here
university of the philippines university
of makati lyceum all of the top-notch
universities i already uh gathered
around and speak around about blockchain
and cryptocurrency
so the agenda for today guys is
blockchain transfer 2022. i know that
you heard about game five so play to
earn
what is it why there's a lot of
companies jumping into game five
i'll discuss that later
the second agenda for today is actually
the blockchain technology jobs most in
demand in 2022 yes definitely if you've
heard that
um
you be uh someone became a millionaire
because of blockchain in cryptocurrency
it is true it is not false it's not a
networking scheme or pyramid scheme but
it's all pure hard work
and third agenda as part of our agenda
is how to gain the skills you need for a
blockchain carrier all right
so i don't know if you can react here i
hope everyone is staying safe and
healthy where are you from i want to
know where you're from guys
please put in the comment section i'll
read that later
all right so
please go ahead jordan india i've been
there but just passed through in the
airport going to israel by the way
india nigeria bangalore i love people
there because i do have a lot of social
media designers e-com tenci web working
for block tides and they're really great
when it comes to uh of course produce
producing designs producing social media
contents for blockchain projects
so johannesburg south africa united
arab emirates i went there like three
times already
how can i read that
hold on
katlano from south africa la union
philippines kabbabayan hello there
jaylin's andrada
york city so there's an nfd event there
so you can actually uh go there purchase
tickets uh we're one of the
media partners as well for nftnyc you
can learn a lot from there
indonesia nepal oh hello there boston
usa kenya bangladesh all right so later
i'll ask again or an icebreaker so of
course
we are all tackling about what is
blockchain guys so
are you aware what is blockchain because
there's a lot of people talking about
nfts
talking about cryptocurrencies but they
don't know the technology behind it
so do you know what blockchain is can
you please put yes in the comment
section
yes
said by hk orlando florida by or uh yeah
i saw it sorry it's too fast
all right
basically guys i'll uh impart the
knowledge when it comes to blockchain
technology
this is just
actually basic
so i'll provide you the analogy the best
ways for you to understand it but in
technical terms i'll run through it
quickly hold on
your chat box became big so blockchain
what is blockchain at first when i was
attending events here in manila 2017 i
asked myself what is blockchain
i mean i really had no idea i was once
like you before attending events
blockchain is kitty party
oh yeah so
actually guys
um
there's a lot when it comes to
blockchain technology it's not just
about financial instruments so i'll go
through about it so blockchain is a
system of recording information
if you've noticed uh when it comes to
data
i'll provide the best analogy for this
in the banking system
so for example you've invested i'm not a
financial advisor okay so when it comes
to your data for your ban
there's a lot of paperwork's when it
comes to
uh you
to be eligible for you to have
or for you to pass their requirements
right you need to be
uh you need to have a
you need to be a graduate you need to
actually be 18 years old you need to be
like this you need to be like that so
all of the data they're gathering when
it comes to bank
so of course
for banking purposes
it's quite nuisance for you to be able
to pass those documents but did you know
that when it comes to blockchain
it is a system wherein you can
definitely go ahead and see it
publicly
it depends on which blockchain you'll
use so it's a digital ledger of
transactions guys it's transactions is
not just limited when it comes to your
money transactions can also be related
when it comes to handling your data
the handling data when it comes to the
groceries that you have in the iot world
so of course it's a computer system
so blockchain is a technology and
blockchain is not bitcoin okay
so so each block in the chain contains a
number of huge transactions so every
time a new transaction
occurs
our record of that it's of course each
participant managed by known as the
distributed ledger known as dlt
so when it comes to like this guys i
know it's very hard for you to
understand the technical terms but to
put but to put it simply
instead of having a middleman
it will be from peer-to-peer it's from
end to end not having a middleman at all
all right so of course each block
contains a cryptographic
block so it's it's coming from that
cryptographic hashes the transaction
data
it's all about math here when it comes
to blockchain guys so
you know and you've heard that there's a
lot of
uh systems being hacked
but unfortunately those are the
technologies that has not been audited
purely or
when it comes to
uh the technical aspects of the ddos
attack
trojan attack when it comes to hacking
please choose the right blockchain all
right
so of course this is the difference
between centralized and decentralized
as i as you can see in the centralized
guys it's actually
a handed or controlled by one single
entity but if you can see
the difference between the centralized
and centralized everyone has a say
so there's a lot of people saying that
blockchain is freedom yes it is all
right
so
of course when it comes yeah i'll not
run through dive deep when it comes to
the technical aspects of blockchain
technology because there's a specific um
master class for that that simply learn
can provide so i'm just providing you
the best information
when it comes to of course when it comes
to
this information so blockchain is a type
of shared database so
this is similar to a google document
guys
you know
yeah is it yes it is
it is a type of data science according
to vj that's right so it's all about
data
blockchain is simply handling many datas
at the same time without a middleman
and of course it is distributed okay so
blockchain is a shared database just
like a google document you cannot
manipulate it you cannot alter it but of
course everyone can see it okay
so that's the best analogy for that i'll
not
run through about that as actually um
the host said earlier so of course
what are the important factors for
blockchain
so for example peer-to-peer
when you're going to send money
there's nothing
uh there's no uh
i mean this is time efficient guys when
it comes to sending from peer-to-peer
you don't need to go to the bank you
don't need to go to your uh
you don't need to go to moneygram or
union bank for you to be able to
transfer money it's all in your hands
already using your mobile phone or your
web browser okay peer-to-peer is
actually sending transactions from me to
you vijay okay
all right so the basics actually this is
for us to
explain
how to be a successful entrepreneur when
it comes to
uh
it's all about the experiences that i
have of course yes krishna that's right
without the interference of third party
i'll entertain the questions later okay
so the centralized blockchains are
immutable
and of course for any cryptocurrencies
transactions are permanently recorded
guys so
in the blockchain in the smart contracts
you can see everything it is very
transparent
all right so there's different types of
blockchain
public blockchains private blockchains
consortium blockchains and hybrid
blockchains again these are the
different types
i'll not go through this but you can see
the difference public blockchain
semi-private blockchain private
blockchain how it's handled all right so
public blockchain you can see everything
there
it's uh actually deep dive for this so
of course what are the blockchain
platforms when it comes to blockchain
platforms
uh guys when it comes to this
in ethereum there's a lot there's a lot
of people building use cases for digital
identity
real estates
ripple
can definitely go ahead this is
metaversing from one technology to
another already all right immutable
means cannot be destroyed guys okay so
that's from nihi
so what are the different types of
blockchain
platforms so just so you know an eye
opener the types of blockchain platforms
not blockchain are bitcoin ethereum
binance smart chain polygon hedera
hashgraph and many more
oops sorry
so for the blockchain applications guys
you can go ahead and see
all of it when it comes to health when
it comes to education
the perfect
application for education is actually
through your school records so just
imagine you not passing your paper
anymore
when it comes to your test or your
diplomas can be issued using blockchain
technology
it is possible you can definitely go
ahead and see it in the internet in the
smart contract and there's a lot of
companies doing that already
for real estate
a lot of people
um
a lot of people is doing this and
making a platform and an app and a use
case for a real estate it's gonna be big
when it comes to data management as well
for the iot industry yes it's gonna be
happening so for the financial uh
financial industry guys you can see
there there's a lot of wallets already
financed
i'm not a promoter here okay so binance
you can see their trust wallet safe pal
so there's a lot all right
so
this webinar is about providing
opportunities
what are the real use cases happening in
the industry how
uh yeah how you can definitely go ahead
and
pursue your passion here okay
so this master class guys is all about
uh just the introduction of blockchain
and just for you to know especially the
students out there who doesn't really
know what blockchain is um yes when it
comes to the deep dive for blockchain
yeah there's a lot of uh master classes
that simply uh simply learn will provide
okay
so bitcoin is an application of
blockchain technology
and blockchain is the underlying data
structure it is the technology itself
okay
all right so you can see here all of the
sectors that blockchain can definitely
provide
yeah muhammad's uh
yes there's no explanations of the
basics but of course um i know i cannot
please everyone here in the webinar but
i'm actually just discussing what are
the
uh industries that can blockchain can
definitely disrupt okay i uh the webinar
entails all about the opportunities for
people what can they pursue
so i'm explaining everything when it
comes to the industries okay so for the
cryptocurrency part guys
cryptocurrency is running in blockchain
technology all right
so
yeah
so
the industries you can see it here the
private markets
when it comes to the crowd funding the
derivatives intellectual property and
voting by the way here in the
philippines um
the elections is coming up just imagine
blockchain technology will be integrated
when it comes to voting so it will have
clear transparency when it comes to
the voting system that will have i know
that india already approve of that i
just saw in the news all right so yeah
so the best example guys that i told you
about blockchain is actually
there's no middlemen
all right so from the bank instead of
you
going to the bank
and processing your data your
investments it's you
interacting it directly okay that's
what's blockchain about
that's what the technology is about
all right
so the 13 prominent blockchain
applications of course you can see there
there's already nfd marketplaces
there's already cross-border payments
real-time iot operating systems digital
identity especially for uh the countries
such as africa this can definitely help
there's also a lot of uh applications
and of course
people who's doing use cases for them
to have financial access
for everyone okay
yes uh chin may i'll go ahead and run
through that
so what are the benefits of blockchain
so this are the things that i need to
discuss here according to simply learn
so yeah
blockchain technology sounds like for
browser so
no
um that's a deep dive when it comes to
web 3.0
so yeah so what are the benefits of
blockchain it's time saving it's cost
saving and of course tighter security so
we all know i experienced this in the
philippines i provided my
uh cell phone number my email address
with the contact tracing so guys
there's a lot of people who called me at
the same time by me providing the number
on that tracing app and
my data is not secured already so the
purpose of blockchain
if this will be integrated in the
contact uh tracing like dubai is doing
right now
it will be for tighter security for our
data at the same time okay
all right so what are the challenges
right now when it comes to blockchain of
course education and information money
laundering personal
so be careful when it comes to you
trusting people when it comes to of
course
uh providing news about
the fake news that's happening
the fear that they're creating when it
comes to the minds of people the energy
consumption and of course scalability
there's a lot of blockchains out there
and cryptocurrency that doesn't have
really a use case at all so please be
mindful
in checking uh smart contracts their
tokenomics and their roadmap if you're
gonna check or support blockchain or
cryptocurrency projects okay
all right so of course uh when it comes
to this uh this is the perfect analogy
guys so direct transfer of
cryptocurrency or transactions again
transactions are not just limited when
it comes for you to be able to transfer
data from one to another okay it's
cutting the middleman out
so again cryptocurrency there's a lot
bitcoin ethereum
um
what else
can you please give an example of
cryptocurrency that you know
so there's a lot of important uh
information that i can share but of
course time is limited i'm just
providing you the glimpse of blockchain
technology again the purpose of
blockchain technology is cutting the
middleman okay matic yes dogecoin
bitcoin xrp
you all know what type what are the
other types of cryptocurrencies already
bnb yes so of course
so
there's a lot so i can definitely go
ahead and explain to you the types
of uh information when it comes to
technical aspect but i am told that i'm
gonna provide you the information about
the opportunities the industries only
and yes you are all right tron right yes
mean coins actually mean coins
again guys please be careful with your
investments so if you want to bear in
investing with meme tokens it's it's
fine
but actually hiba inu have a use case
already if you're gonna check it they
already have like a use case going on
so yeah so when it comes to the
electricity impact due to blockchain
i know that ethereum 2.0 is building an
eco-friendly
blockchain already because you know the
tweet of elon musk really impacts a lot
of uh
economic and of course when it comes to
green we support it of course nature
mother nature so eco-friendly uh devices
for blockchain
it's all about computers guys so if you
believe in internet blockchain is
actually uh the next big thing
so
there's a lot of developers already
building a lot of the apps what are the
apps it's actually a browser inside the
browser so that's web 3.0 okay it's all
about it's all about the technology it's
a mathematical equation that is really
hard to
uh disrupt at the same time or decode
so how do you get cryptocurrency of
course
this one i will not touch this because
again
i was told
that this one uh this uh
this webinar is for the opportunities so
how to avoid cryptocurrency scams this
is the
most important part that i can actually
provide you guys so phishing emails do
not fall for impersonators there's a lot
of people who's
impersonating my profile already asking
for money i will never do that social
media scams so there's a lot of people
providing uh in the comments section on
facebook please be careful as well okay
all right so
of course what's the point of
cryptocurrency in blockchain
it is owned by everyone it is impossible
to forge at the same time and yes all of
your transactions and data is
confidential
and yes security grows through time and
value
all right so what are the challenges not
just in blockchain and crypto false
decentralization just be careful when it
comes to the technology itself
and the inefficiencies and when it comes
to volatilities for the price of
cryptocurrencies guys it is massive okay
so the final thoughts here so i'll go
through the blockchain trends now so the
blockchain trends
there's a lot of central banks and
digital currencies
uh already uh planning to have its own
currency if you'll notice that so in
europe there's also there also plan they
are planning to build their own cbdc
it's what you call it central bank
digital currency so here in the
philippines also it's uh digital peso
philippine peso
so that's the blockchain trends that i
can provide you just look it up also
south korea is actually uh building that
okay they're in the process and doing
that yes uh i heard about that in india
that
you will also have your own cbdc soon
and then of course
uh eco-friendly blockchain because you
know there's a lot of people
when it comes to um
fiat currencies they're not believing
fiat currencies anymore due to inflation
due to many stuff okay
so the game fight let's talk about game
five so
what are the game fi projects that you
know
what are the game fight projects or play
to earn that you know guys so i know
axio infinity is the best thing
so yeah
sandbox yeah they're one of our uh
favorites as well this the central land
right right
oh place war
thank you norvin for mentioning that yes
i'm also the co-founder and ceo of place
war so gala games is one of our partners
as well for plays for guys
so yeah mana mere four yes splinter
lands i'm gonna have uh
a seminar with them so just follow place
war block tides for the latest news sin
city yes i also love that
so of course
nfps become the next big thing so when
it comes to nfps i'm quite curious when
it comes to the regulations as well guys
it seems like you all know
uh you all know about what's happening
already so all of this that i'm
discussing is really powered by
blockchain technology so if you have
more questions i'll uh entertain that
later i'm really sorry if i can't uh
provide you the thorough information
when it comes to the end of
information about blockchain
about the security about all of the
stuff when it comes to technical aspects
okay so nfts when it comes to art it can
definitely help as well
so
how can we uh be a web developer in the
land of blockchain industry so i'll
answer that question later okay okay
so nfts become the next big thing yes
just imagine um here in the philippines
there's also
a project building for nfc music at the
same time it's really massive because
this lockdown
made a lot of people realize that
everything can be digital you know even
in school just imagine that your child
or your children or you or you as a
student uh can use metaverse platform a
metaverse platform that is running in
blockchain technology so you can create
avatars at the same time uh publish your
avatars uh in the blockchain with the
use of nft avatars with your school ids
so that's very possible when it comes to
blockchain technology
and how many cryptocurrency you own it's
a private uh confidential information ma
sorry so yeah so the rise of the
metaverse as well so metaverse because
of facebook became hype
so mark zuckerberg actually
provided that there they
they are meta already but we didn't know
that metaverse is just built by the
blockchain space in our own words
so metaverse is actually here since 2000
guys so if you actually
uh played the sims before
uh it's about building houses creating
avatars it's all about that also for you
to be able to
upload your youtube videos it's already
metaverse as long as you interact with a
technology it's already called metaverse
uh it's not really a thing
when it comes to technical aspect
all right so yes the best of
organizations are already meta but
metaverse itself with the word guys
um they're all thinking that it's all
about augmented reality
but really it's all about virtual world
that's happening since
lockdown happened so it's called
metaverse so there's a lot of people
making it complicated when it comes to
technical stuff but it's actually right
now what we're doing so interacting via
zoom using this uh platform so that's
what metaverse already yeah i know a new
name of fb is metal so
here so what are the jobs that's in
demand for 2022
so yes there's a lot of jobs oops sorry
so you can be a blockchain developer
where can you find that how can you be
certified of course here in simply learn
they do have uh specific master classes
when it comes to blockchain when it
comes to uh programming
and also ui and ux designer what is this
so it's basically in in a
easy word is basically a designer of an
app the interface in the back end okay
so solidity developer security architect
if that's your passion for it if you
have knowledge you can definitely do so
and actually uh having that so i'm from
congress background how this will help
me
so
krishna if you do have commerce
background this is a big industry that
you can tap on so you can definitely go
ahead and search through seminars that
you can attend as well how to build an
ecommerce app running in blockchain
technology
right so you can definitely do that
because e-commerce is a big industry
that can definitely help when it comes
to the transactions
so by the way guys when it comes to the
traditional jobs
blockchain technology is really abundant
in giving out salaries okay it's really
different just to tell you honestly so
i'm this webinar is for me to provide my
experiences
also for the legal consultants
i know there's a lot of um
legal consultants or
i don't know it depends on your country
but here in the philippines there's a
lot of legal consultants providing legal
opinions about blockchain
uh how they can definitely go ahead and
impact
uh the regulations in your country so
yeah
so quality engineer for example i do
have place war so we're also looking for
quality engineers for you to be able to
check at least the quality of our game
play the reward system so all of this
you can definitely go ahead and learn
each when it comes to the specific
information so there are free master
classes there are paid ones so of course
this is a free webinar i'm just
importing my knowledge
i'm just
sharing what i know my experiences as
well
so yeah
so cryptocurrency analyst there's a lot
so if you actually have a trading
background or forex background you can
definitely go ahead and apply
and uh
just be certified you know there's a lot
of people
um doing free webinars already
just be careful in doing that okay so i
really do trust coin market cap in
providing um
blockchain information cryptocurrency
trading so you can go ahead and uh
follow them coin market cap i'm also one
of their official influencers they do
have this
uh page which is like a wikipedia so
it's called alexandria you can search
all of the technical terms when it comes
to blockchain stuff you can definitely
go ahead and do that all right so when
it comes to trade support manager again
if you do have um trading background for
to forex basically uh here you can also
do that okay there's a lot of webinars
you can ask the host here if they do
provide that uh master classes okay
so of course blockchain consultant you
can also be an advisor so once you know
the general information about blockchain
so there's a lot of people speaking
about it
uh speaking about here and simply learn
along with ec council i'm also one of
their global advisors so they do provide
certification for blockchain
professionals so that's the in-depth
that you're looking for guys so this one
i'm just providing opportunities okay
so that's the certification courses that
ec council also have with amarpreet
so they took me as an advisor
so you can go ahead and approach ec
council they're also based in india you
can go ahead and get through that uh
information when it comes for you to
know the in-depth information about
blockchain okay
so for the project managers of course
in block types i do have a lot of
accounts handling uh for this specific
account so we're also
hiring project managers at the same time
how can you be organized when it comes
to handling this projects
operations wise you can be uh you can
definitely go ahead and do so okay
so
for community managers yes guys so
there's a lot of projects out there um
to be honest in reality that doesn't
have really a good customer service so
here if you're really into customer
service if you're really into helping
people you can also be a community
manager so i do have a lot of uh
people
i hire at the same time as a community
manager for uh the companies that i'm
handling we do have 50 active blockchain
plot projects already that we're
handling uh just for block types alone
and we're also uh
hiring people in place where also guys
so again i'm providing opportunities
here not to discuss blockchain in deep
dive okay
so do you need to be certified to get a
job in tech blockchain space guys
actually um simply learn to offer free
uh classes just go ahead and do so and
there's a lot of internship when it
comes to me i'm also hiring interns so
just look for in linkedin that's where i
actually got my opportunities so i'm
sharing how i got my opportunities by
you searching for it because you know
opportunities are already presented to
you it's already there it's already in
the internet all you have to do is seek
for it okay linkedin yeah
all right yeah i do have i do provide uh
internship when it comes to blog tides
so yes just submit uh at info
blogsites.com
so yeah i already provided this to he
here in the philippines
if i'm actually
happy with your service or your uh i can
absorb you okay
so yeah so according to simply learns
research for the whole i.t
so it's all boiling down to this
before developers are not being seen but
through blockchain technology guys
it's a whole world out there for the id
technology of course data scientists the
internet of things it's more huge it's
more wide when it comes to
tackling things so big data engineer you
can also be like that devops engineer
this is too techie already we can
discuss a lot of things when it comes to
artificial intelligence but again uh the
time here is limited and of course you
can also be a project manager as well or
product manager
so how can you gain the blockchain
skills you need
for a blockchain carrier so there's a
lot guys so i prepare uh i i have
prepared all of this
so according to my experience for five
years all you have to do is improve your
skills in cryptography so of course this
webinar is not served for cryptography
subject so search of course simply learn
easy counsel the one that i've mentioned
to you
use youtube videos for learning so
there's a lot of youtube videos
uh simplylearn also offers that uh
enroll and free blockchain courses
and
the next one is know the basic terms in
blockchain the glossary you can search
on google what are the basic terms
uh for blockchain
there's a lot guys genesis the first
block in the blockchain so yeah so
participate in blockchain events and
conferences
so
yeah udemy is good as well guys
so participate in blockchain events and
conferences as well there's a lot if
you'll search and on google as well
uh coindesk and cointelegraph
posts
a lot of events you can definitely go
ahead and look for free ones if you you
don't want to pay i know of course i do
care for your financial needs as well so
there's a lot of free events that you
can attend such as this simply learn
webinars
and yeah
this is also provided by simply learn so
according to krishna yeah
so
develop
programming uh knowledge programming
knowledge so of course for those uh
people who seeking out or really knows
programming i know there's a lot of uh
people in india i really do admire these
people you people watching from india
uh there's a lot of good developers
there and there's a lot of good people
so yeah there i do have a lot of friends
there as well such as digital notice so
if you know them you can definitely go
ahead and check i i do know
or ask if they're
hiring interns as well for those
students out there okay
yes uh websites like finance academy is
good as well they're tackling trading at
the same time
so
yes it's virtual because of course you
cannot go here uh in the philippines or
singapore we are based in singapore guys
okay
so
this is a free master class for everyone
i hope you're appreciating it so if you
do have questions uh please let me know
in the comments section
all right thank you very much uh myrtle
anne and just
to clarify this is a
webinar about opportunities in the
blockchain industry and
murderland went into
some good detail about the underlying
technology as well so
if you want to get
a deep
understanding of the technology from the
technical level there are certainly
courses that you can take as she
mentioned
including from simply learn
but really what we're looking at today
is
where would you look in the industry to
become
a player
and i think
her position as an entrepreneur and
founder of uh more than one company in
the blockchain industry
uh lets her speak to that very very well
so i want to
thank for that and we're going to go on
to the
questions and answers so let me yeah
because there's some misinformation or
maybe they didn't read the whole topic
for the simply learn web
web page
um i really want to discuss the
blockchain uh technical aspects or run
through about that but this is not the
right master class for that right
yeah yeah that's exactly right so um
let's
go ahead and i'm going to share uh
actually i don't need to share screens
because we're just going to do the
q a but i'm going to go through some of
the questions that we've logged in we
have about
six minutes or so
um
rohit asks if you need to know node.js
to
[Music]
become a blockchain engineer
can you repeat the question sorry
to become a blockchain engineer um
do you need to know node uh js
javascript
yes it's important also cc plus and also
python so when it comes to blockchain
and programming uh you need those stuff
when it comes to building a smart
contract and building uh the technology
the mathematical uh equation but of
course you can provide that simply learn
to have a separate master class for that
right right we have uh you know
different programs for that i'll touch
on those later
um
so
what if somebody has no background in
programming uh
no javascript experience that type of
thing
how um is it possible for them to enter
the blockchain what are the some of the
career paths that they might
start in
um
before they start gaining that
programming experience
to be honest um for the programming is
that is that the question
yeah what they're they're asking are
there opportunities that don't require
programming
yeah of course so
what uh how i hire people
i'm just gonna share this opportunity
okay so with or without crypto
um
me and my ceo always look for passion
and um willingness and dedication when
it comes to hiring people because i do
believe that uh skills can be learned
afterwards but when it comes to
integrity
um in hiring people and also dedication
that's really um irreplaceable because
it's really hard to
get people who's really dedicated
uh that's that's right so
that's how we hire people
as long as you know
and can adapt to uh a lot of things
you're a fast learner
i can definitely go ahead and um give
you a chance because you know everyone
needs to have a chance here in this
world so i i'm i'm really different when
it comes to
a certain company you know what i mean
right so because
there's a lot of companies who hire like
um people who really have solid master's
degree
uh graduate course yes education is
important but but when it comes to
not the skill based
but for you to be able to have that um
important character
character
and um
yeah character integrity and
how you work is how i look at it's not
about the skills that you have but again
in skill some are important as well but
that's my priority when it comes to
leading my company so for five years we
already done that yeah
yeah and i noticed on
the list of
types of
that are roles
engineering worlds per se there's uh
management and um
management
community managers
like that that are
not oriented toward developing but they
require an understanding of
how blockchain works and what its role
is in
in our
different industries so
those are all
for people who are thought to have a
programming background
so for example we have munch
oh i'm sorry i don't know why that would
happen but there's mentioning different
roles that you had talked about that are
not
directly
project management or
community support and that type of thing
uh manjeet uh
asked a question he's an accountant and
how does blockchain help him
as an accountant right
yeah
excuse me pardon me so when it comes to
being an accountant guys
um there's a lot of people
of course me uh i'll i'll put the
example for block tights and place war
since i do have a company already so as
an accountant there's a lot of
companies and startups who's actually
hiring accountants already for them to
be assisted in their payroll so you can
definitely go ahead and apply because
you know um it's not limited as long as
you have like a free course you can
present it to them uh for example here
you attended simply learn webinar you
can pass it here because you know
uh blogtites is very well known already
globally um you can go ahead and um
share that you actually have a master
class with me
and yeah that's already an experience in
the portfolio guys so that's why
webinars are very important
how and how is uh
watch technology changing the area
i think it's one of the other
investments
sorry uh you're cutting off
storage
oh i'm start i'm so sorry i'm not sure
what that is um
but
how does blockchain technology affect
accounting as an industry
so as an accounting of course there's a
lot of paperworks right when it comes to
accounting i'm not an accountant but i
can really know uh i can provide you the
information that it can solve the data
when it comes to handling data for the
paperworks so of course it's going to be
seamless the transactions will be uh
efficient at the same time in a faster
way
we have people in other industries
chemical engineering electronics
is
this
is a
career that be suitable for them
i didn't hear that sorry the voice is
cutting according to the uh group
chat
i
really don't understand what the
difficulty is with my technology here
today but um for people who
are
uh
other technical domestic electronics or
chemical engineering
uh is
blockchain and here that can move into
as a career
can someone type what i didn't really
heard it sorry stewart
oh my gosh
okay yeah you're cutting off really even
them uh can hear you cutting off
i think i may have a network issue going
on here um
so
let me put the question in the chat then
okay
where is it
it's coming
i think you're
asking about um
how can chemic is that right chemical
engineering
yeah
okay
so for the chemical engineering so i do
know there's a lot of ways that
blockchain can help uh
the chemical engineering so according to
the one that i read before so helping
manufacturers uh
of course dive into savvy energy and
commodity prosumers it's out of the
topic but uh that's what i know so
blockchain can enable them to do uh
fostering secure and efficient megawatt
trading that's for the industry okay but
for of course chemical engineering
i'm thinking of actually
this is so for chemical engineering is
really a framework for the concept so
efficacy transparency uh transparency
and security so what i do advice
if that's your experience is you can
actually go ahead
and check i have not looked into
this aspect already when it comes to the
opportunities for chemical engineering
but i do know there's a lot of
people who's actually hiring when it
comes to science you know health science
and there's a lot of scientists already
developing new processes and application
that might fit for chemical engineering
so you can definitely go ahead and apply
into that industry because again uh
blockchain technology is not limited to
financial instruments but also there so
if you can see actually a blockchain
platform
who's actually uh doing this
with a concept
of course this is direct business to
business transaction already you can
apply there
but it can really help when it comes to
providing chemical manufacturers
uh for a new tool especially its
chemicals so it's all in 360 view so if
you don't know guys blockchain is
actually being used in ar already
augmented reality it's being integrated
it's very powerful
okay i put another one in the uh
can someone without finance programming
or computer science knowledge
get into the blockchain
industry
yes of course so for me i do believe in
that
um
also related to the question earlier so
really find what's your passion about
you know uh what are the things you love
doing
so it's all about finding the right uh
things that you want to do in your life
because you know
after one to five years
you'll be bored or you'll just be tired
with what you're doing
find
a passion
find the things that you really want to
do
and actually that's what i do i really
don't know i really love speaking i
really love helping people i really love
connecting with people
so that's where i actually built block
types it's connecting synergies
so it's all about passion guys so we're
talking about here a lot of um
a lot of uh
jobs or experiences already but it's all
about finding your passion so you'll be
unstoppable you'll really be successful
because i do mindful business conscious
business so
i actually prepared some this is uh
related to the topic
in addition not in technical terms in
the blockchain industry so how can you
be successful when it comes to
this because you know yes you may know
all of the stuff when it comes to
uh the skills the technical aspects but
you have the lack of character but you
have the lack of motivation
so
you must challenge yourself to be honest
so
it's not just uh rainbows and
butterflies and being an entrepreneur
so
again successful entrepreneurs are
passionate about their work
at the same time uh
you must take risk you know me uh i do
have a stable job for eight years in the
call center in the bpo industry but
taking a leap of faith i don't know
where i'm going that's the big leap that
i really took
uh in my career so of course
it's really uh for me taking risk is
actually
just a new energy
so yes we might get scared i don't want
to leave my five years job i don't want
to do this because we're used to in
being in our comfort zone so me that's
the first thing for you to be successful
of course you must take risks as long as
you're not hurting uh people guys that's
what my father actually said to me it's
a really
really good um
learning and lesson for my life as long
as you're not hurting other people take
chris if you want if you really want to
do something
okay
yeah
um
i
think again with questions about
how do you see
healthcare or hospitality
can you hear can you hear stewart guys
yeah he's having issues no audio
yeah i apologize again
hold on i'll just chat him
i'll just send them a message
what applications that does blockchain
have for hospitality
and health care so when it comes to
there's a lot of um medicines right
so when it comes to the data handling
for blockchain technology can definitely
be organized as well as um shipping at
the same time so blockchain can
definitely help when it comes to the
technology for hospital hospitality and
healthcare so i do have this project
last 2018 who is actually
handling for face mask for
face mask as in beauty okay so
uh it's vitamin c so they're really into
health care as well
uh and at the same time they uploaded
everything via blockchain so all
transaction and all of the inventory is
actually uploaded in the blockchain
so
it seems it's very seamless guys when it
comes to transaction data
and handling of inventories for
blockchain technology even louis vuitton
by the way i don't know how to pronounce
it correctly but we call it louis
vuitton
here in the philippines so they do have
blockchain technology integrated
that's what i know that's what i heard
and what i read
that they're handling their um
from shipping i think it's wood shipping
when it comes to their inventory
okay can you hear me now myrtle
okay and i apologize for the audio
problems i have no idea what was going
on
um but that's as much
time as we have for uh
but unfortunately there were a lot
i couldn't get to
because of the
technical issues so i apologize to
everyone there's questions we couldn't
address
um
and
it seems like there's a lot of people
who are very interested in the deep into
the technology itself
so i might ask you to come back at a
future date for another webinar and say
possible technology
um
opportunities but
um again thanks so much for being here
today
and i'm going to uh
go ahead and share ice cream
all right so
even though stewart is actually cutting
off guys so my last
uh conclusion here
it doesn't matter
uh
where you came from your background your
skills as long as you believe in what
you do and yourself you'll really be
successful you know again uh this
webinar is for me to uh motivate
everyone when it comes to being
successful
uh yes you can definitely do so if you
believe in yourself because it's it all
starts in believing in yourself in the
technology such as blockchain technology
and at the same time helping other
people okay so
this is 2022 already let's help each
other let's empower each other let's
motivate each other
thank you so much everyone
okay
thank you again
or
i
and if you actually want to follow plot
place war guys you can play it we
already have the market place so the
marketplace is live our investor is
crypto.com
so
um they're a big backer so please do
support that um let's fight with ukraine
at the same time we posted with place
far at the same time about uh
say no to war only place war so
guys let's help each other
blockchain technology is a is an
abundant technology
um
especially with the wages so just seek
because what you seek is is seeking you
according to rumi that's my favorite uh
line according to rumi so guys please go
ahead and uh follow block tides follow
place war and also um follow me on
twitter and linkedin
if i have time i can definitely go ahead
and um
connect with you via telegram as well
okay
thank you again
as you can see
put up the information about the courses
and our next webinar
and that concludes our webinar
i'll go ahead and read it for you stuart
so go ahead guys and have yourself
certified
blockchain certification bootcamp for
caltech usa center for technology so
this will cover all of the things that
uh the other guy is asking about bitcoin
hyper ledger ethereum ripple multiple
multi-chain blockchain platforms as well
as being a professional certificate
program in blockchain so this is a four
months program guys so
check this out in iit kanpur indian
institute technology so go ahead and
check that out for uh with simply learn
please stay safe and healthy i i already
helped stewart with this because of her
of his uh connection stay safe and
healthy let's help each other and
empower each other bye bye for now